[Musique]
bonsoir je m'appelle annick beauchamp
chaque jour désormais sept minutes vous
est consacrée elle nous permettra
d'aborder chaque soir une question qui
vous préoccupe
quel genre de questions mais celle que
toutes les femmes se posent à un moment
ou un autre de la vie quotidienne
quelques fois ce sont des questions
toutes simples et d'autres fois c'est un
peu plus compliqué même pour les adultes
que nous sommes nos droits tenez par
exemple nous n'avons déjà il paraît
beaucoup mais il nous reste à mieux les
connaître et sûrement à acquérir
d'autres le travail on nous dit qu il se
diversifie pour les femmes que davantage
d'emplois leur sont ouverts à nous
d'exploiter les possibilités offertes
nos enfants mais nous voulons leur
donner le maximum de chance seulement il
nous faut trouver tous les jours des
solutions par exemple comment les faits
a gardé le mercredi les mercredis n'y a
pas forcément d'école il n'y a pas
forcément de garderie aussi ouverte dans
certaines villes des femmes ont pris des
initiatives
elles se sont regroupées elles sont
allés trouver le maire de leur commune
ou de leur ville et l on dit fait
quelque chose vous avez des locaux
puisque les écoles sont vides
beaucoup de personnes seraient contentes
de s'occuper des enfants une fois par
semaine et aussi les autres jours après
4h ce qu'on peut pas organiser un petit
peu tout cela on le peut c'est pas
facile
cela pose des problèmes d'assurance ce
n'est pas facile mais c'est possible à
condition que les responsables de votre
ville le veuille vraiment et pour cela
il faut que vous vous occupiez après
tout vous êtes électrices d'autres ont
obtenu satisfaction alors pourquoi pas
vous à demain pour une autre minute
bonsoir vous avez tout était sensible à
ce remue ménage fait autour de la
publicité six derniers temps et de
l'image de la femme qu'elle reflète
c'est désormais un problème de
conscience qui se posent à tous aux
hommes comme aux femmes
ils se posent à nous les femmes parce
que nous ne pouvons plus accepter une
certaine image qu'on veut par femme
donner de nous mêmes
et puis il se pose aussi à certains
hommes qui eux non plus ne sont pas
d'accord avec certaines publicités qui
ne
se servent des femmes que pour mieux les
séduit e et enfin ils se posent aux
annonceurs aux publicitaires aux
journalistes qui voudraient donner une
certaine dignité à la publicité qu'il
crève ou qu'ils diffusent il ya quelques
mois madame françoise giroud a demandé
aux professionnels de la publicité
d'étudier cette question de l'image de
la femme avec l'aide entre autres du bvp
c'est à dire le bureau de vérification
de la publicité qui a répondu à cet
appel en réunissant une commission il y
avait beaucoup d'hommes dans cette
commission il y avait aussi des femmes
nous avons eu il ya quelques jours les
résultats de leurs travaux ce qui
apparaît c'est que désormais les
professionnels de la publicité devront
s'interroger eux mêmes sur la question
suivante quelle est la vraie place de la
femme dans la société d'aujourd'hui
qu'elle pourrait être cette place si
toutes les barrières
si tous les préjugés tombent et à eux de
faire preuve d'imagination pour trouver
des images qui corresponde à la réalité
des femmes de maintenant alors bien sûr
le bvb n'a pas les moyens de répression
c'est seulement une association de
professionnels dont le but est de
garantir une certaine honnêteté à la
publicité
ces recommandations ne peuvent être
appliquées que par une bonne volonté
commune de toute manière il ne s'agit
pas de brider l'imagination l'esprit de
création des publicitaires il ne s'agit
pas non plus de morale parce que ce qui
me choque moi peut très bien ne pas vous
choquer et vice versa ce qui vous choque
ne me choquera pas forcément non ce qui
est important c'est que dans la
publicité
la femme ressemble à ce qu'elle est
vraiment c'est à dire une personne qui a
un cerveau et qui est capable de s'en
servir
pas un objet destiné seulement à
valoriser un produit ce qui est
important aussi c'est que on ne la
définissent pas comme éternellement
subordonné à l'homme voilà les critères
sur lesquels nous pourrons juger mais
c'est aussi à vous de vous battre pour
que cette image de la femme évolue si
une publicité vous paraît mettre cette
image en danger mais dites le nous
bonsoir vous savez qu'une réforme du
divorce est à l'étude actuellement
cette réforme est tout à fait
souhaitable nécessaire même parce que la
loi actuelle n'est plus réellement
adaptée au monde d'aujourd'hui et parce
qu'elle est dans son ensemble nettement
plus favorable aux hommes qu'aux femmes
espérons que la future loi soit plus
équitable
nous en parlerons le moment venu mais ce
que je veux préciser aujourd'hui c'est
la différence qui existe entre un
divorce et une séparation de corps ont
comme est fréquemment deux erreurs
d'abord on s'imagine que la séparation
peut être décider librement par les deux
équipes
eh bien c'est faux dans l'état actuel
des choses le consentement mutuel n'est
pas plus reconnue pour la séparation que
pour le divorce et c'est un tribunal
le tribunal de grande instance du
domicile conjugal pour être précise
c'est un tribunal qui prononce les
séparations c'est donc une décision
judiciaire
ensuite on croit facilement que lorsque
l'un des deux époux a commis une faute
contre le mariage c'est le divorce qui
prononcé et que lorsque la faute est
moins sérieuse on s'en tient à la
séparation
eh bien pas du tout les motifs de la
séparation et ceux du divorce sont
exactement les mêmes
d'ailleurs la procédure les frais aussi
sans tout à fait pareil
la séparation de corps n'est ni plus
simple ni plus rapide ni moins coûteuse
cas divorce
alors qu'est ce qui change ce sont les
résultats
les résultats seront très différents une
fois un divorce prononcé les conjoints
deviennent lance hommes étrangers l'un à
l'autre il n'y a plus aucun lien
juridique entre eux les biens qu'il
possédait en commun seront partagées et
chacun pourra se remarier dans la
séparation de corps au contraire le
mariage n'est pas rompu les époux reste
marié devant la loi et continue à ce
devoir mutuellement fidélité secours et
assistance
mais il y à deux changements très
importants
premier changement
les époux séparés de corps ne sont plus
obligés de vivre ensemble il n'y a plus
de domicile conjugal deuxième changement
leur régime matrimonial devient
automatiquement le régime de la
séparation de biens
et c'est pour cela que l'on parle
souvent de séparation de corps et de
bien alors que le terme légal et
séparation de corps
il faut donc savoir que cette séparation
ne libère pas du tout les liens du
mariage mais elle peut être disons une
étape transitoire après trois ans la
séparation peut être converti en divorce
sans que l'on ait besoin de refaire
toute la procédure et pour cela il faut
naturellement que la des deux époux en
fasse la demande
voilà donc la situation aujourd'hui il
est vraisemblable que la future loi
modifiera les conditions de la
séparation de corps en même temps que
celle du divorce
il faut donc bien connaître les
différences entre les deux pour mieux
comprendre ce qui se discute
actuellement d'un soir quand les
circonstances vous oblige à devoir vous
défendre vous souhaitez connaître vos
droits
mais les connaître comment vous
envisagez bien de faire appel à la
justice
mais ce qui vous retient c'est que la
justice coûte cher les frais de
procédure les honoraires d'avocats et
tout cela peut représenter des sommes
importantes
alors faute d'argent parce qu'elles ne
travaillent pas ou parce qu'elle gagne
tout juste de quoi vivre
les quantités de femmes renoncent elle
ne demande pas un divorce qui serait
indispensable
elle abandonne l'idée d'une recherche en
paternité elle se contente d'une pension
alimentaire dérisoire fixé depuis très
longtemps et qui devrait être augmenté
mais savez vous que dans bien des cas
elle pourrait vous pourriez bénéficier
de l'aide judiciaire
qu'est ce que c'est
et bien cela veut dire que sous
certaines conditions
on peut intenter un procès où se
défendre si on est attaqué sans avoir
rien à payer ni frais de justice ni
honoraires d'avocat c'est cela l'aide
judiciaire totale les conditions pour en
bénéficier
en gros pour fixer les idées disons que
les ressources de votre foyer ne doivent
pas dépasser 1350 francs par mois + 150
francs par descendants ou ascendants à
charge
il existe aussi une aide judiciaire
partiel là les frais de justice sont
toujours gratuits mais vous devez
participer aux honoraires d'avocat cette
participation est raisonnable allait
baser sur vos ressources
le judiciaire peut vous aider devant
tous les tribunaux civils y compris et
c'est très important devant le conseil
des prud'hommes qui tranche les litiges
entre employeurs et employés
elle peut aussi vous aider à réclamer
des dommages-intérêts devant le tribunal
correctionnel
si vous avez été victime d'un délit d'un
vol par exemple si vous pensez être dans
une circonstance qui vous permettent
d'obtenir l'aide judiciaire totale ou
partielle faisant la demande au
procureur de la république du tribunal
de grande instance de votre domicile en
lui adressant une simple lettre
vous trouverez des imprimés les imprimés
spéciaux mise au point par
l'administration soit la mairie ou alors
à défaut au bureau des de judiciaire du
palais de justice de votre domicile vous
n'avez plus qu'à les remplir et envoyer
votre lettre au procureur dans ce cas
vous êtes célibataires veuves ou
divorcées vous ne travaillez pas et vous
vivez avec un homme sans être mariée
avec lui c'est ce qu'on appelle d'amour
très laid le concubinage
vous êtes tout à fait libre de vivre de
cette manière mais pouvez vous avoir les
mêmes avantages sociaux que si vous
étiez marié vous savez que les femmes
mariées qui ne travaillent pas bénéficie
de la sécurité sociale de leurs maris
malheureusement ce n'est pas du tout le
cas des combines et c'est sans doute à
juste mais des règles ont été établies
il ne suffit pas de vivre avec un assuré
social il faut en plus qu'il y ait de
parenté proche
et célia existe à travers le mariage ou
par la cie la filiation
donc je le répète si vous vivez avec un
compagnon sans être assuré social vous
même vous n'êtes pas protégé
si vous tombez malade si vous attendez
un enfant vous l'avez droit à rien si
votre compagnon meurt avant l'âge de la
retraite vous laissant démunis vous
obtiendrez peut-être de votre mairie
un secours pour vous rembourser une
partie des frais d'obsèques
et pour que vous puissiez touché le
capital décès prévus par la sécurité
sociale
vous devez avoir été à la charge de
votre compagnon de manière totale et
permanente au moment du décès cela
implique que vous n'ayez aucun revenu
par vous-même aussi faible soit-il vous
ne pourrez toucher ce capital décès que
si aucun n'ayant droit direct ne l'a
réclamé dans les délais fixés par la loi
alors qui sont ces ayants droit la veuve
de votre compagnon s'ils étaient mariés
ses enfants s'il en avait et peu importe
qu'ils aient été légitime et naturelle
reconnue ou non ou même simplement
requis autre chose si votre compagnon
meurt alors qu'il est déjà retraités
vous n'aurez pas droit non plus à une
pension de reversions d'aucune sorte
tout ça vous le voyez n'est guère
favorable aux femmes qui vivent en
concubinage sans travailler en revanche
leurs enfants sont mieux protégés en cas
de maladie les enfants bénéficient de la
sécurité sociale du compagnon de leur
mère à condition à condition qu'ils
soient à la charge de ce compagnon de la
même manière il n'y a pas de différence
entre concubinage et mariage pour le
versement des allocations familiales
dans les deux cas dans les deux
situations on ya droit dans les mêmes
conditions
si vous ignorez jusqu'ici ces deux
possibilités et si vous avez des enfants
de moins de 16 ans ou du moins de 20 ans
qui poursuivent leurs études
allez voir d'urgence la caisse
d'allocations familiales de votre région
bonsoir vous travaillez et vous allez
avoir un enfant
l'entreprise qui vous emploie doit
respecter les droits qui lui sont
garantis par la loi en particulier
vous ne pouvez pas être renvoyée parce
que vous êtes enceinte
c'est absolument interdit sauf si vous
étiez en période d'essai bien sûr pour
pouvoir vous lis sensible il faudrait
que votre employeur prouve que vous avez
commis une faute grave ou bien qu'ils
fassent faillite par exemple mais en
contrepartie vous vous avez une
obligation prévenir la sécurité sociale
que vous attendez un enfant et vous avez
trois mois pour le faire à partir du
début de votre grossesse
si vous êtes menacés de licenciement
vous devez remettre à votre entreprise
un certificat médical qui constatera
l'état de grossesse et qui indiquera la
date prévue pour l'accouchement
vous avez sans doute déjà que vous avez
droit à six semaines de congé avant
l'accouchement et à huit semaines après
mais dans quelques professions il existe
des conventions collectives qui prolonge
ce congé maternité alors renseignez vous
bien sur ce point
en ce qui vous concerne vous
personnellement par exemple ou pour
savoir qui vous paie pendant votre congé
de maternité
si vous avez la possibilité ou non de
prendre une année entière de congés non
payés pour élever votre enfant c'est une
disposition très intéressante lorsqu'on
tient à élever soi-même son bébé la
première année mais il n'ya pas que des
avantages
tout dépend de votre situation
personnelle de la manière dont vous
voyez votre vie professionnelle c'est à
vous de peser le pour et le contre et
d'être très informés en tout cas quelle
que soit la durée de votre congé de
maternité vous devez retrouver à votre
retour dans l'entreprise
votre ancien qualification et votre
ancien salaire
si quelque chose vous paraissait anormal
sur ce point il faudra en parler à vos
délégués du personnel ou à défaut à
l'inspecteur du travail dans ce bar
l'année internationale de la femme
vous en avez beaucoup parlé ces temps ci
nous y sommes en 1975
et ce sont les nations unies qui ont
choisi ce thème pourquoi pour quels
motifs pour faire comprendre au monde
qu'il est temps de lutter vraiment
contre les inégalités contre les
préjugés dont souffre encore trop
souvent les femmes les femmes c'est à
dire la moitié de l'humanité
les nations unies ont laissé à chaque
pays la liberté d'organiser à sa guise
sa propre année internationale de la
femme
alors qu'allons nous faire nous en
france beaucoup de choses des actions
officielles et des tas d'actions
individuelles
la première action d'ordre officiel est
pour bientôt
le samedi 1er et le dimanche 2 et le
lundi 3 mars une centaine de femmes de
divers pays européens et autres
viendront à paris et se réuniront sur
l'habitation de madame françoise giroud
secrétaire d'état à la condition
féminine
ce sera le premier acte concret dans le
cadre de l'année internationale
ces femmes sont membres du gouvernement
de leur pays ou bien elles ont des
responsabilités politiques économiques
sociales ou culturelles
pendant ces trois jours elles vont
échanger leurs expériences personnelles
elles feront le point sur la situation
des femmes de leurs pays respectifs
elles définiront les progrès qui restent
à accomplir
c'est à dire la prochaine étape il ya
aussi dans les écoles début mars une
journée d'information sur le rôle et la
place des femmes dans le monde
une mine a fait une manifestation
sportive beaucoup de choses mais cette
prochaine étape ce n'est pas seulement
celle des autorités officielles de
l'année internationale de la femme
c'est aussi la vôtre la nouvelle étape
la nouvelle image de la femme moderne
c'est vous qui l'a créé et qu'il a créé
chaque jour c'est vous qui savez ce que
vous voulez qu'elle soit et c'est à vous
de l'imposer comment il ne s'agit pas de
déclarer une guerre stupide aux hommes
mais de trouver à leur côté un meilleur
équilibre une meilleure harmonie dirait
dans cette collectivité qu'est notre
société vous avez forcément votre
opinion et vous devez la faire connaître
cette année particulièrement puisque
vous le pouvez le 24 octobre on
célébrera en france comme dans tous les
pays
la journée des femmes dans chaque région
les femmes organiseront cette journée
comme elle le voudront alors préparez
vous dès maintenant dès maintenant à y
participer
groupe et vous écrivez ou aller voir
votre déléguée à la condition féminine
ou bien prenez part à l'action des
associations féminines elles agissent
depuis longtemps déjà mais à l'occasion
de l'année internationale
elles peuvent encore mieux faire
entendre leur voix 25 d'entre elles
pratiquement les plus importantes sont
représentés au secrétariat permanent qui
a été créé pour l'organisation de
l'année internationale de la femme et
qui rassemble aussi des représentants de
divers ministères ou des syndicats des
associations de jeunes
ce secrétariat peut vous aider aidez vos
clubs vos associations
il peut vous documenter pour vous
permettre d'agir alors je vais vous
donner son adresse noter la bière comité
national d'organisation pour l'année
internationale de la femme
secrétariat permanent 32 rue de babylone
75007 paris
en tout cas nous vous reparlerons de ces
journées qui lui sont destinés bonsoir
[Musique]